um we have now learned that Donald Trump
had the opportunity to go after Al-Qaeda
terrorist I'm an al-zawahiri when he was
president
Joe Biden recently making the decision
to strike al-zawahiri killing him
but Donald Trump chose not to do it
because he didn't recognize the name
these are now the widespread reports
Business Insider Trump had the chance to
kill Al qaeda's leader but didn't
because he didn't recognize the name
the al-Qaeda leader Ayman al-zawahiri
was killed by a U.S drone strike Biden
announced Monday then president Trump
had the option to kill al-zawahiri but
chose not to NBC reported in 2020. Trump
wanted to kill Osama Bin Laden's son
instead because it was the only name he
knew
can you imagine
um intelligence officials briefed Trump
many times about senior terrorist
figures that the CIA wanted to track
down and kill mentioning al-zawahiri two
people familiar with the briefings told
NBC that Trump chose not to pursue
al-zawahiri because he didn't recognize
his name he instead said let's go after
Hamza Bin Laden he would say I've never
heard of any of these people what about
Hamza bin Laden
a pentagon official told the news outlet
that was the only name he knew
the Department of Defense and a
spokesperson for Trump did not
immediately respond to Insider's request
for comment even though Bin Laden's son
was widely seen as an emerging figure in
the terrorist group he was not believed
to be planning any attacks at the time
the president's preference for a
celebrity targeted killing
um not surprising and listen bottom line
Trump didn't perceive that there was
anything in it for him and Trump
probably rightly assessed I I think this
is almost certainly true if Trump
doesn't recognize the name he assumes a
lot of his followers don't either that
that's probably accurate but also
understand that Trump could make a big
deal out of whatever you know he can
come out and say you know who we got we
got JP also no I'm sorry I'm an
al-zawahiri we got him and this guy was
a big deal bad guy uh I sometimes would
call him Abdul as he often says during
his speeches and it and his followers
would have said look he got JPL zawahiri
or whatever the guy's name is I think
that that probably would work but to
some degree there's this what's in it
for me and killing someone whose name is
Bin Laden is probably better this also
by the way
supports the reasoning for Trump
authorizing the Drone strike on the
Iranian General better headlines it
might incite Iran maybe it makes his
Saudi friends happy you know who knows
and sometimes you have to understand the
two filters one is is there something in
it for me which Trump asks the second
part then is Trump might not recognize
that there's something in it for him and
so if we think back to covid if Trump
had simply said masks are patriotic
we're printing 5 million exclusive Maga
masks only to be made available to my
best and biggest subscribers
um and then we're just going to follow
what doctors say he would have made big
money we know he makes big money off of
the Maga hats he would have gotten
reelected I mean it it really is that
simple and maybe we'll talk about that
tomorrow with political scientist Rachel
bidikoffer as well and by the way he
might have saved a hundred thousand or a
hundred and fifty thousand or even more
lives in so doing but Trump doesn't
always recognize when there's something
in it for him
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the U.S alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100 made from bamboo a bamboo
stock keeps growing it can be harvested
forever it means that the soil and the
ecosystem aren't disrupted no carbon
removing trees are cut down the paper
industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one American uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required put an end to that right now
with real paper the best part is the
stuff is really great it's just normal
Soft toilet paper real paper loves the
David Pacman show they're giving my
audience 30 off your first order and
free shipping when you go to
realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below